hello it's cameron again founder of
stylecraft and a pro motion designer
with
two decades that's right two decades of
experience
welcome to video number two of my
workshop how to design
style frames now in this video i'm going
to teach you
how to easily lay out that style frame
or style frames i should say
and build something that looks dope and
more importantly
this video is going to help you build a
solid design foundation
for your frames because if your base
level design
isn't dope it will never
look pro so if you're a junior motion
designer
but you aren't sure how you can lay out
assets
to create style frames or you're a
mid-level motion designer looking to
really
up your style frame design skills
you'll discover how motion designers
like you and me
can easily lay out dope style frames
and why it's critical that you focus on
this
right now
[Music]
so in video one we talked about a simple
process for
concepting and creating design assets
i shared how this is going to
immediately help you lay a solid
foundation for style frame design
so if you haven't seen that video go
back right now
and watch it and then come back to this
video it's
critical that you watch video number one
first
anytime you're trying to build style
frames it's inevitable that you are
going to hit
roadblocks you might have experienced
some of them already things like
where do i start the images the type
what do i start with or maybe it's
impostor syndrome
telling yourself i am not a designer
and then you start to wonder how am i
going to make this actually look good
you start trying to figure out the end
result before even starting
well here's what i know to be true if
any of this
sounds familiar it's totally normal so
in this video i'm going to make it easy
for you
i'll help you avoid these usual
headaches by showing you the simple
steps
i follow to easily build style frame
foundations
which will save you lots of time and
frustration
so let's get into the meat and potatoes
of today's video and
let's lay out some solid style frame
foundations are you ready okay so here
we are
inside of after effects and believe it
or not
this is where i like to design okay i
prefer to design inside of after effects
for many different reasons a few of them
are that after effects is
non-destructive
unlike photoshop photoshop is getting
better at it um
but you know you have to duplicate
layers inside of photoshop
there are some workarounds but for the
most part
after effects is non-destructive so i
can do things to the layers
and it's the original is still there
right that's destructive
that's non-destructive sorry um also
there's so many
effects and things like that inside of
after effects whereas in photoshop you
have to really
you're limited okay now i do use
photoshop for certain things like
um if i have to do like some serious
cutting out of elements
i'm gonna use photoshop for that um if
it
if i don't feel like i can easily cut
something out with a mask tool here in
after effects
so that's just a little bit of
disclaimer about
designing here in after effects okay so
you're going to notice that i've got a
very wide composition here and this is
2540 by 1080. it's a ratio of 2.35
which is what i decided to do
because i wanted to make this more
cinematic now there's no
right or wrong ratio here okay it's just
how i'm
choosing to design my frames that
doesn't mean
that you can't design an hd which a lot
of times i do design a hd or 4k
it also depends on your client right if
your client says we need a frame at this
resolution you're going to design at
that resolution
so i'm just doing this for cinematic
reasons because i want a very wide
screen look um 25 40 by 1080
i'm going to change the duration to one
second because i'm designing here
and after effects length doesn't matter
because i'm not animating this
okay if i was animating this i'd
obviously want to make the composition
the length for that but
uh doesn't matter with animation so i'm
making it one second so
i want to show you two concepts here so
this can be a little bit longer
so let's move into the textures here
and let's find a grid texture here this
is the one i really liked
like it a lot and i'm just going to
kind of position it
something like this because i thought
it'd be really interesting to use this
as
kind of like my layout right so these
lines can help divide things
up and you know i could do something
like that
where it's more in thirds but i kind of
want this line over here because it
looks interesting to have like an
interesting it's almost like it looks
like an old film frame
over there and let's go into
at this point i just really like to
start playing around right
now you can see in this image i found uh
in the
concepting phase i really like how this
also is divided up into images
i'm also looking at the ground plane
here
so maybe something like that and i'm
going to set it to
[Music]
not overlay that's too intense
but the other thing too is when i'm
playing around transfer modes like this
i also
don't so i'll leave an ad for now i'm
not going to
sit sit here and spend a lot of time
trying to get this just right
i want it to look okay and then i'm
going to start adding
layers to it and then that's when i'll
kind of do my polish at the end to make
it look all
nice and tidy
let's see what else we have here we've
got
the clouds yeah that might be kind of
cool up in here
or something again maybe i'll just go to
a quick
yeah that doesn't do much
yeah we'll just leave it how it is okay
and we're just gonna scale this guy down
this one to be something subtle i don't
know yet
um i do like that plane that we were
playing around with maybe
maybe this one and we'll do
i keep getting so black multiply is to
get rid of
the whites
i always get those backwards
i don't know that's pretty dark so then
what i do here is i'd take
i'd hold down alt or option click and
drag and it just replaces my image
like so
and
[Music]
i don't know it may be too much it's
it's really dark but i'll leave it there
for now i like the elements
i know that over here i want to do like
this atomic
kind of thing so something i played
around with was like okay well i could
put the president
over in here you know something like
that
um i mean it looks it looks pretty good
so maybe i'll leave them there for now
just switch it to overlay now soft light
too gritty way too gritty right
yeah i'll turn that off for now if i i'm
not sure if i'm going to leave it or not
i'm going to go ahead and turn it off
i'm going to lock it and that says hey
don't delete this
because i kind of liked where that was
going so let's keep that in mind
um let's see here where is
we've got some nice tape here
these are interesting i really like this
one here
so i'm just going to draw a quick little
mask
around this guy so i can just use this
one
if i want to get really uh serious about
this i'm gonna hit y
i'm gonna take this anchor point and
drag it in here and this is just
so that like if i do things like
rotation it's gonna rotate on this
close to the center point of this piece
of tape um
don't have to be perfect right it's just
a little bit simpler approach here
um yeah
probably somewhere in there i'm also
just for fun i'm just making this about
like you know like a title see because
we all have titles right so i'm gonna
say
i'm gonna call this um film
i'll say editor
ed deter and in my testing i found i
liked
times new roman a lot so that that's
great
i'm going to duplicate that one bring it
over here
and we'll we'll make this guy's name
josh apple sure
now something i teach in stylecraft i
teach all this kind of stuff but
something i teach in stylecraft
specifically is about typography and
there's some general rules to typography
that you need to be aware of when
designing one of them states that
there's a hierarchy for typography to
like understand how to read it
and there's different rules to that but
one of them is
because editor is a size 50
then josh apple is more important so i'm
going to double
the size of that to 100 okay
and you can see the way that they're a
lot
you know aligned here
is that there's definitely more emphasis
on josh apple here
now it's also easy to make things too
big in
in motion design so i'm actually going
to
let's actually parent josh apple to
editor
and let's just scale editor down
[Music]
and by doing this is keeping the the
relationship between
the small piece of type and the larger
piece of type it's keeping them
aligned how i had them
so maybe something like that there's a
little bit of
visual uh disruption i i guess i would
call it with this line of t
of tape here overlapping this j
and it it kind of bugs me a little bit
but for now we're going to keep it
that's
one thing about designing is you're
gonna see certain things will really
start to bug you
and if they're bugging you that means
you probably need to do something about
it
so let's go back up in here into atomic
bomb
now i thought this image was super cool
um but
yeah actually that's what we're going to
use
so it's a okay size
we're going to set it to
not overlay we'll set it to screen
yeah and it's cool to see some color
here
but for now i want to keep everything
kind of in the general
same vein of color and that's just it
helps me design
right so the easy way to do that just go
up here to color correction
and i'm just going to say black and
white and boom there we go it's black
and white and it already you know
everything's blending together
a little bit nicer here i could play
around with things like
you know the scale to bring it more into
frame
or less to bring it smaller but i
actually like
where it's sitting here so i'm just
going to take my mask tool here and i'm
just going to align it with this line
and just kind of do something like that
right
now the a tool that we can use to
readjust this is y again so if i hit y
this is called the pan behind tool which
you can also access up here
pan behind and i can click and i can
drag and
my mask is going to stay in the same
place
but i'm able to kind of reposition where
the image is now if i go to scale this
up right if i go to scale it up
it's going to affect the mask so then at
this point i'd have to just kind of redo
the mask that kind of junk but
that that right there is looking pretty
pretty good
to me i'm also going to come over here
and i really like i'm really into
redacted text right now which is why
i brought in some of this redacted text
that i downloaded and i'm going to drag
this over here
i want to make sure i switch back to my
selection tool which is v
so v looks like this
actually thinking about this you
probably can't see this because i
replace
my my mouse cursor with a circle
so you can more easily follow what i'm
doing but just trust me on this
v is selection y is the pan behind tool
so for this guy
i'm actually going to bring this up
quite
a bit larger and
let's go ahead and just take the mask
tool here i'm going to divide this image
up into two different
design elements okay so this is one
and let's go ahead and just command d to
duplicate it and we'll bring this one
over here
and for this one i want to do the
opposite i'm going to take the top half
of this
i'm kind of looking to see what's in
here
maybe
i don't know maybe this right here but i
also want it to be smaller i don't want
these to look like they were both from
the same
document so an easy way to do that is
just this
is scaled to 231 percent let's just
scale this one down
and you can see what i'm doing i'm just
playing around with you know different
sizes
and and things like that so and let's
also rotate
i don't know just to take it off
um i don't want everything to be
straight aligned right so
we'll go and we'll take it to multiply
now you can't see that so
what would make it more interesting is
if it was the opposite if it was
white type right so the easy way to do
that is just go to effect
channel and invert now it's white types
we need to change it from multiply to
screen
so think of multiplying screen as two
separate they're opposites of each other
okay so
that's looking pretty good maybe too
much of a rotation doesn't have to be
much right
just a little bit and
i think i want the cloud
to be on top of everything so um you'll
see here in my layer palette
or my timeline that everything is using
the name of what i how i brought it in
here
so we can just hit return and we can
actually change this to like
a spy plane
and this is clouds we'll call it clouds
and this is the rocket
and this is the background texture
perfect that's tape
we know that that's the balm
um so that's looking pretty good let's
also let's do the same thing to this
letter here let's go to effect
uh no it's the last effect we used was
invert so it's found right here
so we'll do invert and then we'll change
this to multiply
screen screen screen screen
maybe something like that and then what
i'm going to do is i'm going to take
that hydrogen bomb
and hit y and i'm going to bring it up
you know maybe something like that so
it's almost like there's this
document now that's explaining this
hydrogen bomb
image i also like to play around
with some other imagery here so like
the gun could be kind of cool let's go
ahead and make it color correction black
and white
let's also
let's set it to screen
you know and like this is my what i like
to do is just kind of
move things around and just kind of see
like is that kind of working maybe
maybe maybe not it might be too much
right it's too big
maybe something like that but it feels a
little bit crowded down in here
so that may not work okay so let's
try a couple things here let's move this
let's actually scale it back up a little
bit
and i'm going to bring off some of this
text here
that'll be kind of interesting to
overlap
these two a little bit maybe actually
bring it up more
i really like this cursive here and
this top secret being over the rocket
here is kind of nice
but i don't need all that type and then
let's go ahead
and let's fix this plane
and i have an idea here let's go ahead
and bring the clouds back in where'd
they go
miscellaneous cloud
yeah let's bring this guy in here
and there we go
so bringing that cloud in here
brings that plane so remember this is
without the cloud
and the plane was just too contrast not
enough contrast i'll take that back
contrast i teach in stylecraft okay you
got to have contrast so
just dropping these clouds in
immediately provides that contrast
for this plane here now i can see the
edges a little bit more distinctly so
we're going to
go back to color correction levels
and just get rid of some of that i think
there might be too much cloud cover now
so and i like that darkness back there
so let's actually
i really like these clouds a lot so
we'll just kind of
play around here a little bit maybe
[Music]
let's actually rotate these guys 180
degrees
because i don't want to take away from
the mushroom cloud here but i do
like this texture that they're bringing
in here
you know i liked it better not rotated
just like that that's nice it's just a
nice little angle there
and that actually gives me an idea here
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
um duplicate my tape sheet
and i'm going to hit m for mask and i'm
going to delete that mask
and i want to bring in some tape here
along the edge
r for rotation i'm looking at this kind
of
l-shaped tape here and that's pretty
cool so what i'm going to do is take my
pen tool
something like this and you can see here
because i took the time
during video one that took the time to
concept and really
bring in a lot of elements that i could
use i didn't overdo it
that's why things are moving so quickly
in this design
phase so i'm just playing around again
with
the different tapes now i don't like the
tapes being so close together here so
i'm going to
undo undo
i'm going to bring the tape a little bit
more off the edge here remember they
don't have to be like in your face right
like the tape doesn't have to be here
fully in frame just a little bit on the
edge here all right that's all we need
very nice this feels a little
overpowering in here and it actually
makes me want to
try something here where i bring the
text
down here
actually let's undo undo let's just take
both of these
chunks of text we're going to duplicate
command d to duplicate
okay and i'm doing this because i really
like how they are now so i'm going to
turn those two off i'm going to lock
them
and then i'm going to take these two
make sure they're both selected go over
here
to my black make them black
and grab editor because josh apple's
connected to that make sure these are at
the top of the layer stack here
and rf rotation for editor
you know something like that then
it looks a little too
[Music]
chris for me and it's also competing
with this type here so we're going to
turn that off we're actually just going
to delete that
i think that this might be too large
it's just too overpowering
so we're going to shrink it down and
just kind of bring it down
[Music]
off off the page a little bit more here
so maybe we'll bring in a little bit
more text maybe that's what we'll do
yeah that's a little bit better it's not
so overpowering right right here
and then something else i wanted to try
with this one is i really liked the
whole idea with fingerprints
which i've got some right here i've got
this one
which is huge so we'll scale that puppy
down
change it to multiply
again it depends where this fingerprint
is right and what's the what's the idea
behind this fingerprint
maybe effect color correction
or channel invert change it from
multiply to screen
that's nice we'll go to effect color
correction black and white
to make sure you can see there's a
little bit of color in there
turn on the original type there
we're also going to add levels to this
color correction levels
and bring out
let's rotate it
let me go ahead and get rid of that gun
actually that's not too bad but i think
it might be too much
yeah it's just a little bit
let's rotate it
scale it down a little bit more it was a
really large file
yeah that's not bad at all so i'm going
to
call this one good this is good for a
rough
style frame right so you can see i mean
there's some things that need to be done
to it to make it really pro level but
it's got a solid solid base here
and that's where we need to be we need
to create a solid base level design so
that when we add our polish to it
it really shines so i'm leaving this
here and we're gonna move on
to the second concept so here we are in
concept
two and for concept two um
same kind of deal 2540 by 1080 24 frames
a second
i'll leave it at 72 frames long
and this one i'm going to approach a
little differently
in the fact that this one can be set up
to animate immediately
okay so this is what i'm going to call
the newspaper concept and what we're
going to do
is we are going to start with
a texture i found that i really liked
the look of
we're going to go black and white again
for this approach
so we'll go color correction black and
white
very nice we're also going to go ahead
and make this
3d and i'm going to go ahead and just
push it way back in z space a thousand
pixels i get ocd about working in 3d
space
um if you don't understand how to work
in 3d space i would highly recommend
checking out 3d camera techniques
on youtube or
around the motion science website or
diving into like ae academy one and two
they
go into 3d layers as well and pro flows
as well so um but i'm gonna push this
back in z space i'm gonna change this to
two views
a lot of times i like to design in 3d
space okay
i find that 3d space is easier to push
elements
back and forth and to really just kind
of get the depth i'm looking for
so that's what i'm going to do here so
i'm going to also create a new camera
and i like to work with one node cameras
we'll go with i'll leave it at 28.
no depth of field necessary boom perfect
i'll go ahead and scale this puppy up
something like
so just
so that we have
it covering the entire frame maybe like
that
and then i like to just start playing
around with all these different
newspapers i have
right so i'm going to bring this guy in
make him 3d
immediately make him black and white as
well
and looking at this
guy i really like this japan us at war
mask tool and
something like that just to crop it and
i'm going to bring in
hit v and bring in
[Music]
my mask here
and since it's a 3d layer i'm going to
go ahead and bring it forward in space
hit p for position and i'll probably
just go the opposite i'll go
negative a thousand
forward something like that
and
you know i don't know maybe scale it
down a little bit
something like that and then i'm just
going to start bringing in
other elements
uh i don't absolutely love that cause i
feel like it doesn't
fit some of what's going on here
so maybe i think
might be kind of cool go ahead and just
what i'm doing here so i've got two of
you set up because i've got a top view
here you can see it says top view here
i also could move into custom view but i
like to work
top views a lot of times maybe side
views
and then just start kind of moving
layers around so i'm messing with the z
and the x scaling them up
and then also just finding some
interesting points
that i like in them so like for this guy
i really like
all this including this image
and may or may not work you never know
having it cut off i mean immediately it
looks a little bit weird to me that it's
cut off like this but we'll see
and then we'll bring in another layer
here
make it 3d black and white
again maybe pushing this guy back
maybe back over in here something like
that
leaving it full right now
and let's go another one oh i really
like that one war is over that's really
nice
so maybe we'll do
something like so make it 3d
and just i'm just going to play around
with all these different
x y and z parameters
something like so and you know it looks
pretty terrible right now right
but how we can start to make this look
more interesting
is by adding a light so we're going to
go into layer
new light and we're going to use a
spotlight
i like to use spotlights and point
lights a lot of times we're going to use
a spotlight um
we're gonna crank up the diffusion we'll
make the darkness a hundred percent
uh intensity a hundred we're gonna bring
down the cone angle
which the cone angle on the spotlight is
if you think of it you know
it opens and closes so you can open up a
cone angle
on a spotlight up to 180 degrees so it
goes straight across and out
i'm going to kind of close that in to
about well
we'll do 54 degrees and boom there it is
and immediately i'm gonna go back into
two views
and i'm gonna zoom out here and i'm just
gonna bring this
light somewhere in here so that
you know it's casting an interesting
light
on this right we still don't see a whole
lot of depth because
none of these newspaper articles are
casting shadows
so what we have to do i'm going to take
my camera and light to the top
i'm going to select all of these top
layers i'm going to lock the back layer
and i'm going to hit aa just like that
and it's going to open up
cache shadows and it defaults to off but
if i click
on they're all going to immediately
start casting shadows
and you can see immediately how much
more interesting
this is to look at with
cast shadows enabled right so
we'll bring this guy in make them black
and white
same process here and if you want you
know i don't have to necessarily
um be masking all these out
right now because what we're trying to
do is just kind of get an interesting
kind of composition interesting vibe
going on
and i want to kind of
get that before i really start masking
and fine tuning things so again
a a turn on cast shadows for that guy
and maybe this guy you know is closer
to the foreground maybe something like
that and then scale
down
[Music]
i don't know something like so i don't
know yet
i'm still not loving this i absolutely
don't like
this at all so i'm gonna go ahead and
bring that back like so
[Music]
i just don't like the way it's cut off
like that
something like that okay now because
this is a style frame about the cold war
again i want to include some typography
here i always like to use
type when possible on projects
so i'm going to type in the
cold war and you're going to see that
when i dropped in this layer here of
type
into the 3d layer stack it's a 2d layer
here
it immediately threw things off so if i
delete this watch the shadows here
see how things kind of got funky there
so i'll talk about this a little bit
later
but for now we're going to make this
layer 3d
and maybe keep it where it's at
in terms of z space it's kind of at
layer 0.
i'm going to change it to a different
type face and in some testing i did
i found i liked this one called
abolition there it is
a lot of times i use typefaces and fonts
from adobe type kit i don't find that
i'm i'm
rarely ever buying any typefaces between
what you can find on adobe type kit
and what you can find for free there's a
whole lot of choices out there
and they work for me so so
let's go ahead and play around with this
let's actually bring it forward
z space
and i'm just clicking on z and dragging
it forward something like that
and i'm going to space out
some of this type
maybe scale it up a little bit
you know something like that i'm gonna
bring this down
and i'm going to make this type
like an interesting red color
i just like the look of black and white
versus red
that's looking okay
but something you can do here to really
kind of
change up the look of
type is to add some texture to it
and to do that we are going to make this
layer 3d as well
and we're going to parent this layer to
the cold war
layer and then we're just going to find
like some interesting texture which i
really like the texture up in here
i could you know i want to avoid the the
typography
for the most part so we're going to find
some interesting texture and this could
be anything it doesn't have to be a
newspaper but it could be anything
and we're going to say okay texture
you need to look you need to be alpha
matting
through the cold war okay so what we can
see here
now if you don't understand alpha mats
and things like that again i would
refer you over to
ae academy one and two we're going to
teach you a lot about alpha matting
luma matting things like that so right
there
we're back to black and white because i
made the image
the texture image black and white and it
looks pretty cool i want a little bit
more contrast in there so we're going to
go into
color correction and we're going to go
back into levels again you could always
use curves
i've been on a levels kick lately
and it's going to make this a little bit
more contrasty i guess
that's what i'm looking for here not too
much because the texture just has to be
um subtle right it doesn't have to be
too much so maybe something like that
um and then what i can do is i can
duplicate the cold war
bring it down below turn it back on and
i could say hey i want this texture
to actually kind of be an overlay mode
of that that red texture
and let's drop down the saturation of
this red
it's really really really really really
red
make it a lot darker
you know something like that for right
now
and then i want to see a little bit more
of the cold war so i'm going to bring my
light maybe a little bit more
up in here actually i'm going to undo
that i'm going to hit i'm going to open
up the light here
transform and point of interest just
move the x
you know don't want to see the whole the
whole word
but uh there you go okay so that's
looking pretty cool
um i'm gonna go ahead and save this so i
don't lose anything
uh japan and us
it's a little bit too much in your face
maybe something like that
and at this point i'm just going to
start playing around
with positioning oop gonna go ahead and
lock that layer
i'm gonna lock all the text for now i'm
just gonna start playing
with positioning shadows
things like that i'm actually going to
unlock
these layers and i'm going to bring down
the cold war
i like to use a proportional grid here
to
get my rule of thirds kind of going on
and that
is a point of interest right there so
that's good
if you don't know about proportional
grade the rule of thirds again i teach
this in stylecraft
you can go up to preferences uh previews
i'm sorry grids and guides grids and
guides grids and guides right here and
we just have to set up a proportional
grid of three
by three click ok and that's going to
give you this
this is a point of interest point of
interest point of interest
point of interest and then you can align
things to these different
lines horizontal horizontally and
vertically as well
it just it's a proven design
skill that or fact that these interest
points
are our eyes are drawn to them so that's
why i'm putting that there
and it doesn't mean you have to like
ultimately stick to those points it's
just a good
place to start
so again you see i took this image
up in here it's okay not to see
everything
you know we don't have to see everything
i don't like how intense the shadow is
on this background here i'm actually
going to take
my dirty paper here and try something
we'll try and do a
channel invert yeah there we go so see
now instead of a white background it's a
much darker background and it looks a
lot more interesting
but let me go ahead and lock that again
this
shadow is too intense back here it looks
like it's just too close to that layer
if i go back to a two view here you can
see well there that's why it's
it is really close to it so let's bring
it forward
maybe in here and then let's scale it
way down
[Music]
so that it kind of gives that illusion
of okay well maybe this is farther back
in space
than we think it is right so maybe
something like so and
oh it's okay
let's take a look at this guy
maybe this one's
you know somewhere in here over in here
that's kind of interesting
i want to i don't want to overwhelm my
type
with imagery here so maybe maybe
something like that
we'll go back and start looking at some
of these
that's really nice like the extra
so we'll go back to color correction
black and white
we'll make him 3d
and let's go ahead and move this guy
somewhere in here
so i just turn on the shadows for this
layer
that's pretty cool
go back to our original images again
what is this
a a for shadow oh let's make a 3d a a
for shadows
cash shadows on
[Music]
we'll bring this guy forward in space as
well
scale this guy down
[Music]
and again i'm just looking at placements
here
in the next series of lessons we're
going to really fine-tune
the look of these because looking at
this
you can see obviously that there's very
hard edges right to these
these papers right and you can tell
they're digital papers like this one's
not so much but it's got this
weird background but this digital edge
hard edge to it
it just doesn't work right it looks too
digital so we need to do some things to
soften up the edges
and some more things like that so we
will like i said get back to that
um in the next set of videos but for now
these will work just fine just cutting
off some of that
weird edge there
and i'm trying not to overpower
too much here
and again i'm just looking i really like
the shadows that are being cast here
and i'm making sure to select both
layers of text
to move them so i moved them a little
bit above
my rule of thirds but that's okay i said
it doesn't have to be exact
keep coming back there
i really like that image a lot it's very
powerful
it's kind of scary
let's make them 3d a a cast shadows
perfect and
scale them down
scaling back up
and i want to put a little bit in right
in here
so maybe this guy is what goes back in
here
[Music]
now
this image is just really overpowering
and sometimes this is what happens
um when you see me when i'm i feel like
i'm struggling right here to kind of get
this all
solved but once it does
it all kind of come together
and i'm just going to mask this guy
make them black and white make them 3d
aaa cast shadows
and push this guy back in here
oh yeah that's that's starting to work
now
it's looking pretty good
yeah i think that that might be too much
it's just a little bit
uh too perfect right so i'm trying to
create like this sense of
um almost like chaos
and i'm going to take both of my
and you can see guys what's going on
here i'm just i'm playing around with
placement
of elements and things like that and
just trying to get
get it to look good um
this is really bright which is why i
think that's what's throwing me off
about it right so let's go into
let's go into curves and
is that affecting anything
nope let's go on to um maybe this is why
i've been on a levels kick lately
it's just so bright so let's go into
um effect color correction
exposure and let's just drop the
exposure now
so that's that's a lot better just make
it a lot darker
and we'll try turning this guy off
yeah now it feels like there's too much
going on right
but we'll come back to that when we when
we finalize some of the
elements when we come into the polish um
that's where we're really going to like
solve some of these problems
of too much happening
if i turn that guy that's not the one i
want
maybe that's too much it feels really
heavy on the left side
so i'm going to kind of break some of
these apart a little bit
give it some breathing room
i'm okay with this yeah
i'm okay with this one this is getting
better
you know i talk about how we all want to
just keep tweaking and tweaking but
you can see here it didn't take me very
long to just create
this basic layout right so let me just
move a couple
more around let's go here
yep and
i just keep wanting to move this guy
around huh
uh that guy and that guy
bring him up a little bit more
yeah and i'm good i'm good right there
for
this style frame that's going to do it
for um
concept one and concept two okay so
let's do a quick review of what we
covered today
first we saw a whole new way to think
about how to easily build style frame
layouts
and you can use what you've learned here
today to immediately
help you up your design skills plus you
found out how to approach
style frame design simplistically so
you know how to move through this
process quickly
it's been a jammed pack video so make
sure
you review what you've learned today and
you put this into action
right away remember that practice
makes perfect okay speaking of taking
action before we go today
please leave me a comment right below
this video
and the next video i'm going to show you
the entire process of adding what i
call polish to your style frame so you
can rock
out seriously love pro level
style frames this lesson builds on
everything we talked about today and
most importantly it shows how
just adding a few simple layers can
dramatically and i mean
dramatically change your frames
so take what you've learned here today
and start putting it
into practice maybe you're just in the
beginning stages or maybe you can apply
it
right away to some some frames that you
have in mind
the key thing is to get moving you'll
want to take these small steps
which will get you to where you want to
be
next up i'm going to share video 3 which
helps you
finish your style frames out and make
them look pro
i'm so excited just knowing what a
difference this is going to make for you
and i
cannot wait to see you in the next video
you